es otra jornada de protestas contra el
gobierno de Benjamín netanyahu Pero esta
vez no por la reforma judicial que se
encuentra paralizada sino en rechazo a
la propuesta de presupuesto que el
parlamento israelí comenzará a debatir
esta noche presionado por sus aliados
Ultra ortodoxos y de la extrema derecha
el Primer Ministro israelí aceptó
asignar unos 137 millones de dólares
extra para el Ministerio del neguev y
Galilea que es manejado por el partido
radical poder judío y también para
fortalecer los subsidios que reciben los
estudiantes Ultra ortodoxos que asisten
a las en total el presupuesto asignaría
unos 1.600 millones de dólares para
instituciones Ultra ortodoxas mientras
sus críticos sostienen que no hace lo
suficiente para abordar el alto costo de
vida en Israel que según varias
encuestas la principal preocupación de
los ciudadanos de ahí el enojo de estos
manifestantes y de los sectores
seculares de la sociedad israelí que
califican el plan de un saqueo a las
arcas públicas y que perpetúa un modelo
que la mayoría de los judíos Ultra
ortodoxos no trabajar ni asistir al
ejército y además se financia la
educación en escuelas privadas que no
brindan algunas materias básicas como
matemáticas ciencias o inglés De
cualquier manera con estos acuerdos en
el Tañón logró aplacar la rebelión
interna a asegurarse los votos
necesarios para aprobar este presupuesto
y de esta manera evitar una caída del
gobierno que se hubiera producido si el
presupuesto no se aprobara antes del 29
de mayo con esto en mente se espera que
la sesión de la kennese se extienda
durante la noche e incluso hasta mañana
hasta lograr la aprobación final de este
presupuesto